this is easily the best arc
so far and one thing that stuck out to
me as being particularly
amazing concerning this arc and well the
entire series really is how much is
conveyed through subtext or
through dialogue implicitly now these
words might sound boring but
trust me it's actually really cool and i
want to show you all why today
everything in this manga hunter hunter
is driven by character
and everything flows naturally from one
scene to the next
nothing feels contrived and as a result
this arc held my interest
and attention and never once let go
and so the time has come for me to
finish this incredible arc in the only
way
i know how by giving you all my first
impressions of thoughts on and blind
review
for the mysterious the compelling and
the gritty
york new city
[Music]
[Music]
okay so remember the cliffhanger i left
things on in the last episode
yeah well somewhat interestingly this
arc didn't at
all proceed or conclude in the fashion i
thought it would
unlike most shonen that more often than
not focus on action predominantly
towards its latter sections this story
had a surprisingly sparse amount of it
though with that said it most definitely
did have some and
it is in my opinion fantabulistic a word
i just made up now to effectively convey
my enjoyment of it and i will most
definitely be talking about the action
in
a little while however more on the main
plot side of things as it's unfolding
after the boys get apprehended a happy
surprise i was greeted by almost
immediately was
how interesting and fun the phantom
troop happens to be
there's a tremendous effort from tagashi
in this material to communicate and
perhaps more importantly
characterize various members of the
troop these aren't mindless red shirts
these are
real characters with personalities
morals wants and
even goals whether it be the cam but
cool nobunaga who by the way has a name
that for whatever reason
without fail reminded me every time i
read it
of the sound the mask akuaku makes in
crash bandicoot in addition to him
there's the creepily upbeat and cheery
shall narc
the sinister feitan and the level-headed
paku among
many others point being by the time i
reached the end of this arc i was fully
familiar with
all of these colorful characters and yet
oddly enough despite receiving
most of the focus and dialogue perhaps
in this entire section
their leader cruello still feels like an
enigma to me
but more on that in a little while the
opening scene sports a heavy tension in
the air as pacu one of the phantom troop
possesses the ability to read their
minds
once they are asked a question
unsurprisingly they try to ask about
karapika but
interestingly as has been made evident
throughout this story by them
consistently referring to him as
quote chain dude they actually don't
have any idea what his real name is and
as a result gon and kilauea legitimately
have no idea who they're talking about i
swear the tension that's built up during
these scenes
was spectacular whether it be that
exchange trying to get information out
of them or
gone's naive expression when he sees
hisoka chilling out with the group made
all the more sweet by kilauea
effectively finding a way to hide
that fact by pointing out that the girl
sitting next to hisoka
was the one gone beat in the arm
wrestling contest
little decisions and workarounds like
that made this scene flow
perfectly and maintain a tremendous
tension throughout however with the
conclusion of this fun scene
it became very clear what the troops
goals currently are
to make sure that these two boys don't
escape and eventually meet crollo
and for the troop to get revenge on the
chain
dude for killing oovo what follows this
scene are probably my two favorite
scenes from this opening section
the first is an obvious one as golden
killer was escaped from the watchful eye
of nobu stuck with seemingly no way out
and taking the lead on this killer
readies himself to give up his life for
the sake of his friend but
gon never want to give up amazingly
repurposes the information he learned
from earlier in this very arc
concerning the forgery of antiques in
order to escape this particular
situation against nobu again this is a
nice callback but it once again
highlights a fundamental struggle for
killua's character despite wanting to
give up on his past to move on from his
family
those habits he learned there still
cloud his mind and
had it not been forgotten in this
instance killable would have convinced
himself that there was no other way
out of this situation apart from
sacrificing himself
now that's a great scene and i don't
want to take anything away from it but
that's only one of the two best parts of
this first section
the second part i think is a lot better
so this is a super interesting turn of
events for a few reasons
first of all we haven't really had a
chance to see what sort of charisma or
personality krollo brandishes
secondly there's this implication that
he's now after effectively kidnapping
the mob boss's daughter
and thirdly he possesses the ability to
steal
other nan users abilities meaning once
he gets his fortune from neon he'll be
free to use his fortune-telling ability
to predict
other people's future and good lord the
reaction that he had to his
own future's fortune was unexpected to
say the least
after all the talk about crolo and all
the outlandish or extreme characters
we've met
in the troop thus far one thing that's
really surprised me about him has been
how meek and calm he appears outwardly
and as it happens this choice was made
to enhance the contrast
once he does eventually start fighting
because the guy is an
absolute beast so as i mentioned above
right we
haven't really had that much of a chance
to see krollo perform or
interact with many people thus far in
the story but that's about to change for
with every decision he makes every
sentence he speaks or
order he gives to his subordinates it
offers us as an audience a deeper
insight into the warped mind of this
chaotic
and terrifyingly composed individual
take for example the order he gives to
the troop to make a
show of themselves on top of the
destruction they inflict on the town
being disastrous with plenty of
casualties
it's not the bombastic destruction that
receives a big page spread in the manga
it's by no means the chaos that receives
the focus from this sequence
instead it's the looming presence of one
crollo as he peers down on his subjects
from atop a skyscraper
loving every single second of what
transpires beneath him he is very much
the orchestrator or conductor
playing his sinister instruments for an
unwitting and defenseless
society and in the manga this page is
laid out specifically to draw attention
to his hands
to create that comparison and i love
that furthermore this blitz by the troop
on the city is
chilling and graphic in its depiction of
the troops hard acts of murder
dismemberment
and decapitation it also offers a much
greater insight into the individual
members that we've all heard speak and
bounce off of each other
conversationally but now we get to see
them
fight together the visuals are gruesome
and mixed into them are some truly
chilling throw away lines like shalnok
saying that his toy broke
referring to a grown man being
manipulated by him ultimately dying
horrifically in the process overall it's
a great and effective set piece to
familiarize ourselves with what i assume
will be their main obstacle in the
material to come and to give us more
reason to hope that our heroes can pull
off the victory here now
obviously all of this is happening
outside and as i mentioned in the last
video
xeno and silva killer's patriarch
figures are both being hired to take out
crolo i mean it makes perfect sense that
the mob would have a retaliation
of some description to this disaster and
destruction and a response they most
definitely
deliver these are two supremely powerful
and highly respected assassins
and characters in this world and to say
that i was excited to see how the fight
would unfold would be a
massive understatement silva and zeno
versus crollo it is finally time for the
zoldic family patriarchs to shine
killua's father and grandfather having
only seen a glimpse of his father in the
prior short-lived arcs it's sort of
surreal game to see them strut their
stuff now
finally and going into this i was
curious to see how capable they really
were compared to a force
we've been getting to know for the
duration of this arc and interestingly
before the fight begins they actually
give
a lot of security personnel time to
vacate the premises to spare their lives
they don't seem to hold any malice or
indifference towards life they seem to
value it which is kind of surprising
given their line of work and given that
they're approaching a character that can
steal powers i think that's pretty
interesting from a visual standpoint the
flow of these panels in the battle
between the three of them
are handled masterfully and flows
perfectly at one point i even felt as
though the panels were actually moving
something i had only experienced before
in dragon ball's manga there's a soft
but
tense nature to the beginning
illustrations particularly on this
extremely detailed rendering of chromos
face that without delay shatters into a
dramatic and frantic typhoon of combat
match
perfectly by the sketchy line nature of
the drawings purposely selling the
intense panic of the situation but what
i found interesting about this sketchy
frantic nature of drawing is that
the speed and power of their movements
is offset by the respective composed
facial expressions of the participants
in other words i love how this scene is
handled
i mean mr zoldick uses a single strand
of his hair to prevent a knife he was
stabbed from
poisoning his entire body which is just
one of those shonen tough guy acts that
i can't help but laugh at it's just
ridiculous
also another thing crullo mentions that
one tenth of a milligram
of this particular poison is enough to
paralyze a whale
which okay how does he know this is he a
scientist a marine biologist
does he go around measuring what effects
this poison has on the biggest creatures
he can find
i mean if that's true i mean it's pretty
weird the fight also helps to cement the
two zoldick's dynamics with kilo's
father silva being the clear
front-runner in terms of strength and
agility made obvious by his actions and
by his constant checking on his
father's physical status despite this
the grandfather zeno while lagging
behind in those departments
still acts as a great support player for
silva all the while brandishing a
cunning and perceptive personality as he
breaks down what sort of name croto's
power system stems from and by the way
the respect
shown between this father and son is
honestly frightening with zeno saying
that at one point
as he pins him down that silver should
land the killing blow on crollo
even if it kills him and without
hesitation silva accepts this
it was around this time that i realized
this fight is doing more for these
characters than an expository
conversation ever could there's just so
much
substance and meaning that colors the
choices and actions carried out through
this sequence
and speaking of colors after seeing both
the 2011 and 99 versions of this fight i
have to say that the fight was handled
perfectly fine in 2011 but the classic
99 version delivered some of the best
animation and storyboards i've seen from
this entire series so far and really the
1999 version of this anime has been
firing on all cylinders for the entirety
of this arc and even as it reaches its
climax it does so by being true to the
characters in question with us privy to
the strengths of both zeno and silva we
observe that zeno figures out the
abilities of
crolo faster than silva all the while
silva attempts the finishing blow
because
he is stronger everything leans into the
respective characters strengths and
as a result in the space of just one
fight scene takashi has taught me to
love these characters
and their dynamic tremendous writing
now this ending to the conflict i
absolutely didn't see coming and once
again it's a character-rich moment that
does a ton of leg work for the zoldic
family mere moments before the conflict
ends we see the aftermath of the strike
landed by silva as he receives
a call from none other than his son
illumi
apparently illumi all of this time was
contracted to take out
all the dons and so with all of their
employers now terminated
silva and xeno go on their merry way
without finishing the job on chrollo
once again it's all business as usual
and nothing personal and what's more is
it's a great way of preserving all of
these characters in a believable way
it's just so good and the best part of
the illumi sequence at the end is that
it facilitates the progression
of the auction as planned thus
furthering the story and leaving
kurapika to pick up the pieces as he
views the doctored or set up crime scene
where chrollo's corpse lays but
something i think that's worth
mentioning at this time was
one of the starkest differences brought
to my attention between the two animated
versions it should go without saying
that
i am trying to be as objective as i can
here or as fair as i can
but at the end of the day it's really
all subjectivity it's down to my tastes
and your tastes clashing so please don't
leave with the impression that the 2011
version of this show
is inadequate or isn't worth watching as
millions of people prefer this version
or have nostalgia for it it's great
with all of that said however i noticed
that something seems to be somewhat of a
trend when i compare
these two versions and that's how the
respective anime adaptations try to
capture a particular tone of a scene
after the fight reaches its abrupt
ending and the auction concludes
kurapika is shown
walking carrying the eyes of his fallen
clansmen now
even if i ignored that all the music
used in 2011's version of this scene is
laughable and does not at all match the
tone of the scene
the visuals unfortunately do nothing for
the scene either
flat with strange textured shading and
low detailed hair
and i understand that many people don't
bother reading the manga or checking out
older versions and if this is your only
exposure to this scene then
you might not notice but i personally
saw this right after reading the manga
and seeing what 1999's adaptation did
for the scene
check it out
compare these two clips side by side and
hopefully you'll start to get a sense of
what it is that the 2011 version is
missing in this instance
[Music]
so [ __ ] peek is walking around carrying
some eyeballs and all sorts of upset
because
these phantom troupe members seem to be
dead even though we as an
audience know that they're not however
it did throw me off balance for quite a
little bit while i was reading
furthermore the craziest thing about
these guys is that they leave behind no
sort of trail or breadcrumbs no
information to analyze about them not
even
birth records which apparently point
them to being castaways from a certain
place known as
meteor city i i'm guessing that will
come into play later
this place accepts pretty much anything
but will not accept anything being taken
away which is an interesting precedent
to set i wonder if something will go
there
and gone will try to take it back but he
won't be able to i feel like that's what
they're setting up but not 100 sure but
yeah these apparently are the only rules
that this place abides by and thus the
search for their identity seems to be at
a dead end in other words we are
currently dealing with forgotten or
unwanted children that later became
adults who became
assassins eventually which i mean kind
of makes them a tight-knit family group
of sorts
remind you of anyone in other words the
fema family continues to run strong in
hunter hunter so strong in fact that
even after crolo reveals that the
spiders will lose
half their numbers they all assume that
means that half of them will die which
again made me think well okay
technically speaking the poem never said
anything about death just that the
spider's group's numbers will be halved
in theory someone or a bunch could just
leave too it's an interesting
stipulation but
also like everything else in this story
is written in such a way that reveals
in this instance the familial bond they
all share no one even entertains the
possibility of betrayal which
tells us more about their bond than a
simple explanation ever could
and this scene as they read their
fortunes and eventually piece together
what they must do to reach their goals
crolo confronts nobu and in a way tells
him to give his life
to protect the others that are more
important to their operation and as
perfectly timed as i've come to expect
from takashi as nobu agrees to lay down
his life
to change the prophecy hisoka portrays
them all
by secretly leaking sensitive
information to krapika
about them a large component that acts
as the foundation to this arc is
krapika's suffering
under the weight of his own conscience
and sense of responsibility there's so
much negativity hatred and blood
surrounding this poor character who
as i mentioned in last week's video has
already shown us that he doesn't take
any enjoyment out of hurting people let
alone ending their lives
and thankfully this upcoming section
contains some long overdue and truly
sweet moments
finally some happiness for krapika
reuniting with gone and everyone he
smiles for what feels like the first
time in
ages the band is finally back together
however once kurapika meets up with
everyone he lets it slip that he's the
chain dude they were speaking about and
because kilowatt's character is hella
consistent he freaks out and represents
kurapika for giving them that
information
because he knows there's a girl on the
phantom troop team that can
read minds and will read minds i love
all of these little moments and
character consistencies whenever there's
a potential combat situation or whenever
he's dealing with a foe
kilowatt always seems to have his head
screwed on for the next logical thing to
do
well for the most part he sometimes
needs help from his friends
with all that said however because of
this development the plan is to go
on the offensive now they still need
that reward money for greed island
we then switch scenes to crolo dishing
out all the troops fortunes back at the
hideout
i liked it but to be honest this was
where i encountered something in the
manga that i
didn't like and it's not the first time
this sort of thing has happened either
in this material with these sections
offering tons for me to enjoy like the
insight it offers into the dynamics of
the various troop members
and while also pulling double duty with
some tasty dramatic irony with hisoka
being the traitor in the group you know
it seems like a scene i should love
unconditionally and i almost would if it
wasn't for tagashi's desire to overly
explain something in a really clunky
manner sometimes
i've spoken at length over the last
month about how effective tagashi can be
at serving up exposition in creative and
seamless ways
whether it be through the decisions the
characters make what they say or don't
say to each other or even through their
own desires but
this doesn't happen here during this
scene hisoka quickly replaces his
fortune thus hiding his true intention
of trying to fight crolo
and this is a perfectly fine and
creative situation using nen but
tagashi much like his explanation for
how hisoka dismantle castro back at
heaven's arena
is bogged down in so many specific and
explicit expository dumps that it
honestly feels a bit like school and it
kind of feels like someone's lecturing
me
these sort of explanations are present
in a lot of different anime and stories
but
these two specific examples in hunter
hunter felt overly bloated and
complicated for what was actually being
explained bungee gum contains the
properties of both robber and
gum museum i feel like this is one of
those instances where less is more and
he shouldn't need to hold her hands
through everything unfortunately as i
mentioned in the prior video
this was what i was worried about when
nen was explained there are so many
wonderful upsides to a more complex and
involved power system like nen but
this is just one of the seemingly
inevitable downsides
more complicated things can't really be
explained easily without first divulging
a ton
of information onto the reader to act as
an explanation but yeah
that's probably the only instance where
i thought the plot struggled during this
portion of the arc and it's all upticks
from here on out
so we're finally heading into the
endgame of the story and again this
breaks the tradition
of normals shown in stories in a sense
there's no earth shattering or
even city-shattering ramifications to
this looming altercation between the two
groups but we are heavily involved
because we know who's involved and
what's hanging in the balance for them
it's gripping stuff kurapika explains
his ability with the chains in detail to
the guys and together they make a pact
one that bonds them using his chains to
a certain promise
it's sort of screwed up but also kind of
touching to see them as close friends
yet again
kilauea goes to scope out the place but
a bunch of nen buildings have been
erected by one of the troops thus making
them next to impossible to find however
it's here something interesting comes to
my attention kilauea and melody tale
crollo's group
right and during this scene i thought it
was fun to see how powerful melody's
hearing really was
and how the use of it makes her notice
how quiet all of kylo's steps
really are she even asks if he's an
assassin it's an interesting character
moment
and i honestly thought that was a really
subtle but interesting piece of
character
interaction someone like killua that has
quite literally refused to follow in his
father's footsteps
still can't help but walk with them out
of habit and it's that sort of attention
to detail that makes this a phenomenal
series
i mean earlier in chapter 107 there's a
conversation between gon and kilauea
wherein kilauea remarks that because the
world thinks that these folks are dead
that there's no real point in continuing
to pursue them considering
there's no reward so that they can get
closer to greed island and this
interaction i think it's a really easily
missed moment but it's one of my
favorite interactions from the entire
arc and i'll tell you why because
this line by kilowatt mirrors almost
perfectly
how his father and grandfather handled
the crolo situation when they were
facing him earlier in the arc
wherein they left one of the most
dangerous men in the world go
because it was just business there was
no profit for them with their bosses
dead they had no incentive monetarily
anymore and
this is exactly what killer was doing
with gon at this moment in time
however unlike his father and his
grandfather kilauea has a friend to help
him to continue fighting for reasons
outside of business
these are dangerous people they are
going to do horrible things and right
now it seems gone has a plan to get the
greed island game while still pursuing
the phantom troop in the first place
as mentioned prior this arc really
doesn't have impactful stakes that
affect a large scope of people
in fact the scope is remarkably small
and i say remarkably small because
i really care i'm invested i want to see
how crappy cause story comes to a close
or
resolution and i want to see gon meet
his father for the very first time
it's a long journey with plenty of
unexpected twists and turns and
this is another one of them with golden
kilowatt both captured by the troop the
new plan becomes try to find a way to
avoid
too much information being leaked now
that they know so so much more than they
did the last time and
this girl has the power to read minds
with a single touch so
they better beware but even more
worrying kilowatt and gone now have no
communication with
anyone well almost no one one of my
favorite characters had an elegant
solution to this problem hilba begins to
whisper to himself hoping that melody
hears him and then
as if by magic this happens my crotch
my cross hey has anybody seen my crotch
lately
[Laughter]
one of these days i'm gonna catch you
and i'm gonna carve my name on your back
with an ice pick
i love la oreo and i don't use the word
love very often but this is such an
elegant beautiful solution to this
unique problem
nen is awesome and now we have a plan
they will wait until seven the power
will cut and then killer will attack in
the confusion and the way this plan is
laid out in the manga is honestly just
beautiful it's brilliant
i love the choice takashi made to use
the radio in the hotel lobby to act as a
countdown of sorts to when the lights
will eventually cut out i love that we
as an audience are made fully aware of
the plan beforehand and therefore
anticipate it all the more thus raising
the tension particularly when the lady
that can read minds
touches them it's amazing and the small
brawl that ensues after the lights cut
is brilliant with killua acting like the
monster he knows how to be by breaking
her arm all the while
gone follows up the attack with a
massive kick to her face
and despite them being recaptured after
the initial flurry something comes to
the attention of the group
something really important krolow
has vanished amidst the chaos it's a
solution that facilitates this exact
incident without the secrets surrounding
krapika being spread beyond this woman
for if she tells anyone crolo dies this
arc really has just done so
so much for krapika as a character the
precautions he lays out the toughness of
his persona the determination he
brandishes the cold-blooded nature he is
conducting the phone call with and
abducting crollo has been nothing short
of stellar
it's incredibly cathartic watching as
these spiders slowly figure out that
krapika
really does have them wrapped around his
finger as he forces their hands
and sends them all back to their hideout
leveraging chrono's life when utilizing
melody's power and luring the
mind-reading girl to the desired
location alone
there is one small issue however crollow
isn't remotely unnerved and kilauea and
gone
are still with the phantom troop
eventually though an exchange is made
and through this exchange we
actually get to see the discussions and
arguments erupt
amongst the troop these aren't potty
monsters from power rangers or some
random goons
these are all real characters and while
they have a common goal they have
different philosophies and seeing how
these mindsets and approaches clash
and respond to this unique situation was
fascinating
reinforcing not just the bond between
them but with the audience too they feel
like a family these are incredibly
compelling characters made all the more
incredible in this arc's conclusion
typically speaking as a reviewer of
these japanese stories i
choose to read the manga first as that's
the primary source
it's the closest i can get to the
author's true intention for the scene
that's not to say i dislike anime i love
anime i don't have anything against it
and i think it can be brilliant if done
correctly but
just like anything else it can be done
incorrectly hunter hunter is
in a rather unique position where it has
been afforded
by the anime gods two separate anime
adaptations and
throughout this series i pointed to
numerous instances where i felt like the
anime failed to capture the true essence
of certain scenes
whether that be down to the music the
animation implementation or
even the direction at times of the scene
and let me make something perfectly
clear hunter hunter isn't the only story
that this happens with it happens with
almost every anime
even some of my favorites take this
scene from dragon ball z after goku
deals the finishing blow to frieza
he looks down towards the crater with
disdain i mean
who doesn't remember that moment who's
seen the series it's a very iconic shot
so anyone who's a fan of dragon ball
would be very much familiar with that
scene and think they understand what's
going on here or
so you would think if you only saw the
anime
you see in the manga this scene has one
subtle difference
and this subtle difference changes the
entire
scene in the manga after dealing what he
thinks is the finishing blow to frieza
goku is left with this look across his
face
there's no disdain there's not even
really anger
there's just pity and sorrow this is why
reading the manga first is so important
to me it's just to get the most accurate
interpretation of the events and then i
can look at the anime afterwards
however there is an instance in this
portion of hunter hunter that i can't
help but draw attention to
and point as being absolutely incredible
here and now throughout these last four
videos i've been comparing two separate
adaptations as well as the manga
one from the 90s and early 2000s known
as the 1999 anime and one from the last
10 years known as the 2011 anime and
this arc
this video is where the older crisp
version of the show ends
in a spiritual sense but what an ending
they deliver there's a scene towards the
end of this arc where after delivering
the kids back to karapika paku resigns
herself to death
in exchange for delivering unto her
teammates the necessary information
using her net the manga's version is
great and 2011's is perfectly faithful
to that
but 1999's version of this death scene
is
the most incredible of their adaptations
in this series
bar none and this is what in my opinion
any and every anime adaptation ought to
strive for the artwork and direction is
top
tier stuff taking precisely what made
the manga scene great and elevating it
to new heights using the strengths
of this medium it's chilling it's
emotional and it left me with my jaw on
the floor
it's stunningly beautiful it's as close
to perfect as i can imagine a scene
adaptation
can be now there's a little more to this
arc like hisoka
looking for someone to fight but then
realizing that he can't fight crollo
and eventually how we desert crollo on
top of a mountain somewhere awaiting his
crew
but honestly it's near impossible to
beat that scene with paku it's just so
good so i'm gonna leave it with that
scene because
honestly it deserves it over the last
month i've come to appreciate the 1999
version of the story quite a bit and
it's not going to be the same without it
moving
forward in its current glory and so
while with the closing of this video
i'll be closing the book on york new
city and starting my new journey on
greed island next week
in this video i'll also be closing the
book on a tremendous adaptation of a
phenomenal story
capping off its run with one of the most
stunningly tragic and magnificent scenes
i've ever seen
in an anime and just like everything
else in this story it's still
ongoing gone's next objective is to
acquire the greed island video game and
i can't
wait to see what more is to come as we
catch up with this amazing story
but that'll have to be left for next
week but until then don't forget to
subscribe to stay up to date and if you
enjoyed this series let me know by
leaving a like and a comment down below
see you all on greed island next week
[Music]
you